mesdames messieurs bon dimanche le
Canada et les pays alliés ont annoncé
une nouvelle série d'engagements de
plusieurs milliards de dollars pour
permettre aux troubles ukrainiennes de
repousser l'invasion russe et blindés
des munitions des systèmes de défense
seront acheminés vers Kiev saint inclus
200 véhicules de transport de troupes
que le Canada a commandé et qui seront
envoyés sur le terrain au cours des
prochains mois en réunion en Allemagne
le Groupe consultatif sur l'Ukraine a
réitéré sa promesse de maintenir son
appui aux troupes de volodimeki
[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous bonjour
tamian c'est une plaisir madame vous
étiez avec vos collègues des pays alliés
à Rammstein vendredi pour discuter de ce
qui pouvait être fait pour pour
l'Ukraine pour aider l'Ukraine qu'est-ce
qui ressort de cette rencontre
chaque fois
nous avons discuté les capacités les
capacités de chaque pays et nous avons
discuter les choses que nous pouvons
faire pour fournir
l'Ukraine avec l'aide militaires
importantes et ça c'est notre objectif
de fournir la militaire et capacité
défensive pour qu'il puisse se faire
population est-ce que l'Ukraine a
présentement en main les éléments dont
elle a besoin pour se défendre à
l'équateur
l'Ukraine continue
de besoins d'autres choses les capacités
les véhicules blindées et comme j'ai
annoncé cette semaine 200 virus dans des
Canada mais d'autres choses aussi les
systèmes de défense aériennes les
munitions
les vêtements pour l'hiver ce sont des
choses importantes pour l'Ukraine pour
la fin de la gare et nous avons discuté
tous les jours
le ministre raisin et j'ai parlé avec
lui aussi le mercredi passé et il m'a
dit ok le crâne a besoin beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de capacités se sont dit
à responsabilités
partenaires plus de 50 pays qui était là
donc c'était une bonne rencontre pour
tout le monde surtout pour l'Ukraine la
capacité de contribution du Canada vous
avez annoncé l'envoi de véhicules
blindés vous avez acheté des Américains
un système de missiles le Canada la
contribution canadienne de myope bien
modeste parce que les réserves
canadiennes ne sont pas particulièrement
bien garnis jusqu'où est-ce que vous
pouvez encore contribuer à l'effort de
guerre ukrainien
nous faisons les deux choses en même
temps nous avons une politique
depuis 2017 pour les Forces armées
canadiennes aussi même temps nous devons
faire notre part pour protéger le
démarre passé avec nos alliés avec nos
partenaires donc nous continuons
d'appuyer le printemps le cours et le
long mais qu'est-ce qu'on a en stock au
Canada qu'on pourrait envoyer de plus en
Ukraine qu'est-ce qui nous reste à leur
envoyer
bien sûr
nous continuons de
discuter
les besoins de l'Ukraine avec nos
fournisseurs ici mais aussi j'ai des
conversations avec le chef d'état-major
de la Défense pour s'assurer que nous
examinons
tous les options tous les choses que
nous pouvons faire dans l'avenir
l'Ukraine va le dire
d'assaut veut entre autres les fameux
léopards dont dans le Canada dispose
l'Allemagne refuse toujours de donner
l'autorisation d'envoyer ces chaleurs
là-bas est-ce que ça fait une différence
à quel point est-ce que ça mine la
capacité de l'Ukraine de se défendre
correctement comme j'ai dit l'Ukraine a
besoin beaucoup de capacités et
l'Allemagne n'a pas fait une décision
pas encore mais en même temps nous
sommes unis et l'Allemagne a fournir
fournir beaucoup de choses à le prendre
déjà donc c'est notre objectif
de continuer de fournir le canal avec
l'aide donc la base dans le cours et le
long terme comme les véhicules planétum
les systèmes de défense aérienne comme
les munitions et nous continuons comme
pays comme partenaire comme allié de
continuer de faire ça mais sans les
chars sans les chars que réclament
l'Ukraine est-ce que l'impact de l'envoi
de tout l'armement que vous avez annoncé
le Canada et les pays alliés au cours
des derniers jours est-ce que est-ce que
l'impact de cet armement là ne sera pas
limité sur le terrain
[Musique]
il y a des pays qui donnent
capacités comme les systèmes de défense
à rien mais aussi les véhicules beaucoup
de sortes de véhicules bien sûr donc
nous avons discuté beaucoup de choses
pas seulement
les chars beaucoup de choses parce que
c'est une maman crucial dans la gare et
c'est une moment de souvenirs que nous
sommes unis avec nos partenaires
madame madame vous êtes allé à Kiev
cette semaine c'est votre seconde visite
sur terreur sur le terrain là-bas
qu'est-ce qui a changé entre cette
semaine et la première fois où vous êtes
allés sur le terrain qu'est-ce que vous
avez vu qui est différent c'est une
bonne question parce que j'étais là de
janvier passé
et c'était une pays où tout le monde
était heureux
et cette semaine quand j'étais là ce
n'était pas le même chose
j'ai vu des édifices détruites j'ai bu
des voitures brûlées et il y a une
impact cette gare sur les familles qui
veulent habiter en sécurité et en paix
mais ce n'est pas le cas maintenant vous
avez dit cette semaine de votre visite
que c'était inspirant et déchire
qu'est-ce qui est inspirant qu'est-ce
qui était déchirant clairement ce que
vous avez vu sur le terrain les visages
des gens les voitures brûlées déchirant
qu'est-ce qui est inspirant
les gens ukrainiens
le courage
leur bravoure et aussi le résilience
avez-vous l'impression que cette guerre
l'Ukraine peut encore la gagner
oui
oui bien sûr
c'est possible et nous
allons continuer de fournir la militaire
dans frire notre aide à le crâne
parce que ça ce n'est pas seulement la
guerre pour l'Ukraine la soft
souveraineté de l'Ukraine c'est aussi
une guerre pour la démocratie dans le
monde entier et aussi pour
l'ordre international fondé sur les rats
donc c'est une garde pour tout le monde
c'est pas seulement pour les Ukrainiens
on est sur le point de souligner le
premier anniversaire de l'invasion russe
combien de temps les Ukrainiens
peuvent-ils encore tenir
on sait pas ça à ce moment mais on doit
continuer d'être là pour le crâne avec
les capacités dépensées pour
[Musique]
eux parce que ça c'est une moment comme
j'ai dit important pour les ukrainiens
et pour la démocratie
de la Défense nationale merci d'avoir
été des nôtres merci beaucoup au revoir